welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss this is philip molina nice to meet
you
yeah we're re-meeting you every time
because you could be a new watcher and
welcome if you are billy's got one big
bite-sized question that he's going to
answer
us so philip this question was submitted
by at baby once a jeep
how do how do wolverine baby needs a
jeep
how do wolverine's claws work when his
wrists are bent
so imagine that just bent wrist bit
wrists but the claws go up into your
wrist so uh
into your arm you get out of my question
okay at first it's kind of like
why is this a problem he like he can
bend his wrist right
right no this is so much more
complicated i created a very accurate
representation you created yeah all by
yourself i stay up all of them
sit all night doing this alexi helped
okay okay he helped
wolverine he goes like like you come
come they retract yeah come at me
usually metal because i'm magneto
yeah and he's like ah oh my god you got
real close
yeah try it again i kind of don't want
you kind of afraid too so that's like
wolverine story now you guys know what
wolverine's like here's the issue
does he have to be careful about his
wrist yes
he actually always has to when they draw
him in the comics
he has to be coming at someone with his
wrists perfectly straight and his hands
straight so flesh with this
you can't do one of these it has to go
straight like with a with a punch or a
hook and it gets really complicated
actually as to how it works
all right so the reason is if his claws
are stored in his forearm
which it is in various forms of like
x-rays that they've released and also
beads and stuff yeah they they can show
it actually there's different versions
where it sometimes is on top of his
other
bones sometimes it's between them his
online is radius
and then it pushes through the
metatarsals and weirdly moves the bones
out of the way so they can shoot out of
roughly where the knuckles are
so here's the issue he starts to extend
his claws
but his wrist is bent then the claws
can't bend
too so they would shoot out of the wrong
part so if i were to bend this
see now where these claws are
theoretically coming out of
is out of my wrist yeah up here yeah
instead of out of where my knuckles are
or if i went this way i can't do it
because i'll actually have to pierce my
own hand yeah i'll come through your
palm
and they actually showed this there's a
time there's two times they're
interesting
one wolverine got really drunk once on
nowhere
cause he had like basically space liquor
and it actually affected him which it
almost never does because of his healing
powers
and so he gets so drunk that he forgets
to straighten his hand and it
shoots out of his palm on all three
claws and he's like whoops and he looks
like really stupid
another time in the age of apocalypse
story
i don't know you're trying to catch a
picture
uh he gets his um he gets his hand
well i think it's like melted off by
cyclops not triclops
[Laughter]
and he has no hand and so he's fighting
and people are like oh so he doesn't
have claws
no you stupid idiot i stuffed the claws
in the farm and he shoots the claws
out of just the stump oh um but it works
pretty cool though yeah it's very cool
cool cool no doubt no doubt
here's what's so confusing about like
the physics of all this so okay if he
were to bend his wrist later
also a problem i'm pushing the claws all
the way through
right that's like as far out as they go
so now they've
left his forearm and they're
theoretically just in his hands now
now come at me okay
wait don't stop me you have
sharp pencils why don't you just use
noodles
use noodles al dente is fine trust me
i trust you uh you don't get injured
you just injured me you poked me through
my shirt
you don't get injured don't you take it
i don't want to break it
but well yeah i don't have another
sharpener
so if he goes up and he goes ah and he
all the claws are all the way out to the
knuckles they would snap
off when he goes to actually try to
appear somewhere
because there's there's no the leverage
is all the way on the outside
and they're barely hanging on by these
little baby nubs here right okay yes so
then this means
okay his claws must be a lot longer then
right they still have a significant
portion of the claw when it's
[Music]
what are you trying to do you'll see
[Music]
okay so there are a lot longer claws you
say eric oh sh
who is this who is this
security take her away no i'm gonna do
it
oh my god
so you're like oh the claws are a lot
longer and covered in saliva
so then this is how they stay in right
that does make sense for when you push
them
out for it's like like now come at me
no come at me i'm going
okay so if it goes unbreakable
[Music]
i get it if my forearm is much
larger the amount of claws that go back
here is a lot longer it can push out
and it's still strong so if i if you if
you came at me
it wouldn't break i have all this power
but the problem is when i
reverse uh extend uh-huh retract track
and it go back it literally would go
past your elbow yeah so he would have to
walk around like you do sometimes
you're uncomfortable or like the the
woman who never moves her arms and
seinfeld yeah exactly so
he wouldn't be able to bend his arms for
that to work
so immediately this character is like so
deeply flawed
his claws cannot work hey guys eric boss
once again here in the blue dungeon
present day but before we continue with
this i want to thank
bang energy for sponsoring this video
oh lord almighty every can of bang is 16
ounces it contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine it is sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes so good with
over 20 different flavors to choose from
one of those great flavors is sour heads
it's not too sour it
has that like nice sweet kick that a
nice sour candy has without the
part of it but unlike sour candy zero
calories in this
yeah i can get i get down with this
check out bang on instagram you can get
25
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code
newrockstars25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea
keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
i have an answer as to how his claws
actually have to work it's like the only
way that this makes sense
one is yes they do have to be a little
longer
than what he sticks out there okay it's
not fully extended there is still
amounts
left up into his form but it's a very
precise amount that's actually the
length of his forearm
because his claws are part of his mutant
abilities and not what was given to him
with the advantage they were bone claws
they're bone claws then they would
naturally just kind of be almost a
replicant of his ulnar's radius so
they're just the right length where
they're exactly the length of his
forearm
and then they extend a few inches out
but
any artist that overextends them in
shows which they do all the time
they show these like multi-foot long
katanas he's walking around they're
compensating for something
designs yeah exactly because he doesn't
even need them to be
it's unrealistic they're swords at that
point he basically just wants them to be
about finger length knives
or even like maybe six inches out and
like four inches still inside
which is roughly the you know a 10 a
size 10
shoe means you have a 10 inch forearm do
you know that your foot is the size of
your forearm hold on
look now people know i'm wearing shorts
you've been trying to hide that for
years we got them
come on out everybody i'm chris hanson
with dateline nbc
we're doing a story on adults you show
too much leg
can you do it i'm about to rip something
so what are we doing he's got claws that
are exactly the size of his forearm
a significant portion of it still stays
inside his form it does
not stick out that far everyone else is
just exaggerating
this is a really key part look at his
costume design look at the gloves and
look at the little metal shades that
they've
included little minerals right these oh
the sheets that go right yeah okay over
each blade
they're actually directly to address the
come at me problem where they snap
off they hold them in place but and
here's my
proposition he must internally have
his own bone version of those shades in
there that's also
anchoring them so the leverage problem
doesn't happen where they just fall out
wolverine's got bone sheets yes and if
you look
in a very classic design x-ray design
it looks like they kind of attempted to
squeeze that in really quick they put
these little circles there and they
didn't really like acknowledge them
but that has to be it so he has little
bone
holes in there that hold the claws in
place and then partially it's up there
and it's exactly the length of his
forearm it's the only thing that makes
it i love it now what if they retract
like
lightsaber toys where they they fold and
fold and then fold yeah
could they do that like a human case so
really you only need this much space
in in here that it could work yeah so
they don't
should i not have that yes
[Laughter]
there's your bite-sized question
[ __ ] well
thank you to everyone who submitted
questions continue to tweet us
at new rockstars using the hashtag the
big question for all your nerdy
questions that
you want answered in horrifyingly
accurate scientific terms be sure to
find our audio version
at the big question wherever you get
your podcast so you can listen to audio
versions of this while you're driving or
working out or whatever your new year's
resolution is
and you can follow us on twitter at ea
boss at philip molina
anything else we should add follow new
rockstars follow new rockstars on social
media
rockstars happy new year
[Music]
this
[Music]